[Musik]
es ist donnerstagabend
20.15 wir melden uns aus berlin aus dem
alpen telegrafenamt in der mitte der
hauptstadt
zehn tage sind jetzt noch bis zur
bundestagswahl hier wird heute abend
wieder klartext gesprochen live im zdf
mit rund 70 bürgerinnen und bürgern die
hier bei uns im studio sehr herzlich
begrüße
die nadeln und natürlich auch
schokoladen ihnen zu hause herzlich
willkommen auf dem heutigen gast bei
klartext und das ist die
kanzlerkandidaten der grünen annalena
baerbock
erwerber guten abend hier im studio sind
natürlich wieder alle getestet und
natürlich achten wir auch auf abstand
deshalb sitzen die gäste ein bisschen
auseinander gezogen frau berger das ist
also hier heute abend ihre
herausforderung hier sind wählerinnen
und wähler aus allen teilen des landes
und aus verschiedenen politischen
richtungen das natürlich auch einige
sind uns bekannt weil sie schon mal für
zdf-sendungen interviewt worden sind
andere sind unserem aufruf gefolgt den
wir über zdf heute gestartet habe und
wieder andere hat die redaktion entdeckt
und eingeladen zu den themen die diesen
wahlkampf bestimmen das geht dann von
der rente bis zu corona von zuwanderung
bis zum widerstand gegen windräder ja
und manch anderes mehr zum warmmachen
frau berbalk mal die erste frage die
heiße phase des wahlkampfs läuft ja
jetzt sie sind die erste grüne
kanzlerkandidatin aber die umfragen
sehen sie ja jetzt schon ein bisschen
länger eigentlich nicht mehr an der
spitze spielen sie noch auf sieg oder
doch eher auf platz klar sonst würde ich
hier stehen und heute abend diskutieren
sehr sehr viele menschen im land sind
noch unentschieden und es geht jetzt
eigentlich um eine auswahl zwischen
machen wir weiter so wie bisher von der
großen koalition oder wagen wir einen
echten aufbruch in unserem land und ich
bin zutiefst davon überzeugt dass dieses
land deutlich mehr kann und dafür treten
wir grün an und dafür trete ich als
kanzler kann davon müssen sie hier heute
das rund überzeugen genau so dann legen
wir mal los mit unserer sendung und den
verschiedenen themen wir starten mit dem
thema klima und dort in der deutsch
polnischen grenzregion wo viele den
geplanten kohle ausstieg nicht verstehen
weil direkt drüben beim nachbarn gerade
ausgebaut wird
[Musik]
rainer danzig ist reiseleiter in oybin
einem luftkurort in sachsen klimaschutz
ist ihm wichtig denn seine heimat soll
schön und sauber bleiben
ich fühle mich natürlich solchen
anliegen auch verbunden aber eben nicht
auf spektakuläre weise sondern noch
wohlüberlegte und dosierte art und weise
nur wenige kilometer von wien entfernt
liegt das stillgelegte braunkohle
kraftwerk hirschfelde genau neben dem
aktiven kraftwerk turow in polen
dazwischen die grenze das heißt für die
eu klimapolitik das hier weiterhin kohle
verstromt wird und nach den polnischen
plänen soll es ja nicht nur bis 2038
sondern bis 2044 weitergehen
deutschland steigt aus der kohle aus
polen macht munter weiter und doch
scheint sich hierzulande kaum jemand
daran zu stören sagt reinert an sich
hier habe ich noch keinen
umweltaktivisten gesehen der in
irgendeiner weise dagegen protestiert
hätte das wäre eine konkrete möglichkeit
nicht am brandenburger tor nicht an
autobahnbrücken
für rainer danzig ist klar deutschland
allein können das klima nicht retten
und im studio ist reiner danzig herzlich
willkommen wirklich eindrucksvolles bild
hier aus ihrer region was ihre frage
bitte an annalena baerbock einen schönen
guten abend erst einmal und wie sie
gesehen haben wie kommen aus der schönen
oberlausitz und mein zuhause ist der
chor wien und ja die frage ergibt sich
ja eigentlich schon zwei prozent ist der
anteil deutschlands am menschen
gemachten co2 aufkommen weltweit
und daran knüpft sich natürlich die
frage
ist deutschland überhaupt in der lage
allein mit den maßnahmen zu wird sehr
oft auch propagiert und eben auch von
ihrer partei
allein in der lage das zu bewältigen ich
bezweifle das natürlich und sicherlich
viele auch und meine frage ist
dahingegen die
maßnahmen die also von ihrer partei
stärker als bei anderen parteien
favorisiert wird werden im klimaschutz
im umweltschutz umwelt heißt für mich
umwelt und nicht um deutschland also der
begriff sagt ja schon alles so also
meine frage knüpft daran an und lautet
welche erwartungen setzen sie an die von
ihnen gesetzten ziele die umgesetzt
werden sollen die also stärker
strukturiert sind massiver sind als
möglicherweise von den anderen parteien
und vielleicht sogar aus stärker als die
vorgaben die die eu macht ja vielen dank
für ihre frage weil viele in der region
lebt ja selber in brandenburg genau das
umtreibt und sie haben vollkommen recht
2 prozent der emissionen in deutschland
damit werden wir das weltklima allein
nicht retten aber wir als europäer das
haben sie auch angesprochen den beitrag
sind als europäische union gemeinsam mit
den usa die zweit und dritt größten
emittenten weltweit und deswegen möchte
ich als nächste bundesregierung dafür
sorgen dass wir als europa gemeinsam mit
der neuen us administration eine
gemeinsame transatlantische allianz für
klimaneutralität bilden dass wir die
produkte die dann auch in deutschland
viel produziert werden dass die in
deutschland weiter hergestellt werden
wir unseren wirtschaftsstandort stärken
und wenn die usa und europa gemeinsam
das nächste jahrzehnt zur
klimaneutralität einläuten dann können
wir weltweit den großen unterschied
machen insbesondere weil die
industrieländer ja dazu beigetragen
haben dass wir schon bei 11 grad
erderwärmung sind dann sich überzeugt
sie dass ich meine sie können nach polen
reisen nach tschechien reisen diese
deutsche sonderlösung in der region
kommt das nicht richtig an so habe ich
sie verstanden naja es ist ja so dass
die perspektive aus der man viele dinge
betrachtet aus den räumen der
ballungsräume aus berlin aus dem keller
großraum vielleicht möglicherweise ein
bisschen anders sieht als
aus grenzregionen und jetzt gerade in
dem spezifischen speziellen fall wo wir
also das polnische kraftwerk und für uns
ist es ja allgegenwärtig und die
probleme sind ja nicht nur der
zeitliche geplante ablauf also der
weiter lauf dieses kraftwerk was im bild
nicht zu sehen war ist ja die
gigantische grube der gigantische tage
der gigantische tagebau der also mehrere
hundert meter in die tiefe geht und ja
natürlich gewaltige jetzt schon probleme
bereitet und ja ich muss sagen auf
tschechischer seite überleben wir haben
drei länder eck
deutschland-tschechien-polen auf
tschechischer seite ist der widerstand
und ich sag jetzt mal
der erhobene zeigefinger doch etwas
massiver und stärker als von deutscher
seite zur würze jedenfalls bei uns in
der region verspürt also ich finde
selber nervi region viel unterwegs
gewesen und wir hatten sie hat es ja
angesprochen warum wird eigentlich gar
nicht demonstriert gerade mit blick auf
die tagebau erweiterung in polen auf
polnischer seite was sie angesprochen
haben weil das natürlich massive
auswirkungen auf deutschland hat gab es
damals ja vielleicht erinnern sie sich
grenzüberschreitende demonstration ich
warte selber mit vor ort
weil es gerade auch in polen und auch in
tschechien eine zunehmende bewegung gibt
die sagt wir wollen müssen auch raus aus
der kohle in polen werden die gehälter
für bergleute nicht richtig gezahlt die
renten werden nicht richtig gezahlt und
was mir wichtig ist die große chance die
wir haben gerade auch in der lausitz
vielleicht diejenigen die nicht aus der
region kommen wir haben da den spreewald
wir sehen jetzt die auswirkungen
eigentlich finde diesen
touristenregionen dadurch dass das
grundwasser abgesenkt wird durch die
tagebaue dadurch dass die spree vor ort
und deswegen ist ein vorzeitiger
kohleausstieg auch eine riesenchance für
die region diese tourismusregion sie
haben ja selber sind kurorte zu hause
dann in zukunft gemeinsam zu stärken
aber natürlich braucht unterstützung auf
diesem weg dahin ganz kurz ich hab dann
sich so verstand der punkt ist
eigentlich die abgestimmte lösung dass
deutschland sechs jahre früher aussteigt
als die nachbarn dass dort nur riesig
ausgebaut wird müssen sie sich einsetzen
dafür dass das irgendwie zusammen
gebracht wird ja aber das machen wir
nicht nur wie grün rosa von der leyen
bekanntermaßen keine grüne als
eu-kommissionspräsident in hat ja genau
auch deutlich gemacht wir haben eine
riesenchance als europäer mit
klimaneutralität europa als erster
kontinent klimaneutral zu machen
natürlich mit allen eu mitgliedsstaaten
zusammen und der deutsche kohle ausstieg
ist dann im zusammenspiel mit polen und
tschechien genau der weg dahin und ich
glaube dass gerade in der region weiß
nicht wie sie das sehen können sie ja
noch mal sagen aber dass wenn man
zusammenarbeitet auch
grenzüberschreitend wirklich große große
chancen sind natürlich europäisch
abgestimmt er kann sich vielleicht weil
noch andere im raum sind und auch reden
wollen lassen wir das mal dabei wir sind
herzlichen dank wir sind liebe gäste
hier im studio beim thema klima und wenn
sie interesse haben ihre fragen zu
stellen den einen oder anderen die ein
oder andere hand habe ich schon gesehen
ich weiß dass hier andere landwirte es
claudia gute projekte sie hatten eine
frage an frau berg vielleicht schießen
sie mal ab und nahm frau baerbock mein
name ist claudia utah ich komme aus
nordhessen und ich bin land würden wir
in deutschland importieren
rindfleisch aus argentinien
zuckerrohr aus brasilien weizen aus der
ukraine konserven aus china dh die
lebensmittel werden
klimaschädlichste um die halbe welt
transportiert was wollen sie tun um
klimafreundlich die deutsche bevölkerung
zukünftig mit lebensmitteln zu versorgen
wenn jeden tag sieben familienbetriebe
die der verbraucher ja eigentlich immer
haben möchte vor verzweiflung aufgibt
indem wir regionale
in dem der regionale und vor allen
dingen bio produkte aus der region
stärken sieht man ja schon applaus hier
eigentlich überall wo man hinkommt dass
die menschen sagen eigentlich würde ich
am liebsten regional kaufen und auch
gesund kaufen und das was sie
angesprochen haben wir haben ein system
was einerseits dazu führt dass wir ganz
viele importe haben aus dem ausland nach
deutschland rein wo viele kleinbauern zu
machen habe den milchbauern in baden
württemberg heftigst diskutiert über die
frage wie schaffen wir es dass man als
milchbauer eigentlich noch davon leben
kann wenn wir dumpingpreise haben und
auf der anderen seite exportieren wir
auch als europäische union zum beispiel
hähnchenschenkel auf afrikanische märkte
und gefährden dort die kleinbauern und
deswegen was wir tun wollen faire
handelsverträge und folgen der eu
agrarförderung die dafür sorgt dass
nicht mit der gießkanne fördermittel
verteilt werden sondern landwirten
kleinbauern vor ort die sich um
öffentliche aufgaben also um tiere und
gesunde lebensmittel und die böden
kümmern projekte gehen sie ruhig
dazwischen ja ich muss ja leider ein
bisschen widersprechen
mit den verbrauchern ist es leider
manchmal sowie mit den politikern
versprechen auch wenn sie den
verbrauchern das mikrofon auf der straße
vor den mund halten kaufen alle bio und
regional nur warum wird dann noch nicht
mal fünf prozent bio fleisch gekauft
warum fallen die milch tanker mit bio
milch kreuz und quer durch deutschland
werden die biomilch nicht los und die
erzeuger die bio erzeuger bekommen nur
den konventionellen preis
also wie könnte ja eine umfrage machen
wer alles gerne bio milch kaufen will
also gerade bei milch und butter ähnlich
wie bei den eiern erleben wir ja dass
viele menschen sagen ich will genau aus
der region kaufen und wichtig ist die
kennzeichnung haben wir bei den eiern
gesehen als damals gekennzeichnet wurde
massentierhaltungsanlagen freiland
wohnen oder bio huhn dass der verbrauch
bzw der konsum von den eiern mit drei
massiv eingebrochen ist und das brauchen
wir genauso mit blick auf das fleisch
endlich eine vernünftige fleisch
kennzeichnung einige supermärkte machen
das jetzt weil die
landwirtschaftsministerin ist nicht
gebacken bekommen hat zu sagen welches
fleisch es eigentlich aus guter
tierhaltung weil sehr viele menschen
genau dieses fleisch dann in zukunft
auch kaufen wollen aber ich bin recht da
ist noch eine menge zu tun weil wir
derzeit erleben das ebenfalls so wie es
bei ihm jetzt direkt ist viele
bäuerinnen und bauern sagen von den
preisen kann ich eigentlich nicht leben
und überzeugt sie die antwort gibt die
ihnen hoffnung wenn frau berger
bundeskanzlerin würde nicht wirklich
dass ihr vorschlag weil das system
einfacher zu machen das geht ja auch
nicht ob beispielsweise dieser begriff
massentierhaltung wann fängt bei ihnen
die massentierhaltung an als wir unseren
betrieb übernommen haben konnten wir von
20 kühen leben wissen sie was der
landwirt heute für einen liter milch
bekommt
unter den verkaufspreisen die die ist
ich würde sagen 50 cent 31 31
lächerliche sind eine kuh gibt 30 liter
milch das sind 9 euro die ich von der
kuh habe wovon ich mein lohn wasser
strom und und bezahlen muss also dann
braucht man sich nicht wundern wenn dann
auch mehr als 20 kühe im stall stehen
und dann geht die diskussion mit der
massentierhaltung 20 kühe gestalt oder
auch 100 kühe im stall sind keine
massentierhaltung sondern weil es in
sachsen ist es ähnlich in brandenburg
auch da sind diese
massentierhaltungsanlagen weil die
ganzen flächen aufgekauft wurden nicht
von landwirten sondern von hedgefonds
die deine massentierhaltungsanlagen
drauf bauen wo zigtausende von hühnchen
in der fläche von hier meinen schuhen
ein diener 15 zusammengepfercht sind
dass es für mich industrielle
massentierhaltung und die förderung geht
genau in diese systeme mit rein und das
will ich ändern auf europäischer ebene
dass die landwirte wie sie 20 kühe
halten die sich um ihr tier wohl kümmern
dass die unterstützt werden und wir
nicht einfach nach masse gefördert
werden wie derzeit weil das führt dazu
dass viele kleinbauern aufgeben aber ich
sehe es mir haben auf die version bedarf
in zukunft noch weiter führen weil das
ist eines der großen themen unser zeit
gesunde lebensmittel aus der region und
das bäuerinnen und bauern vor allen
dingen deutschland noch weiter fallen
merkte man sieht freute die skepsis an
die bleibt aber sie sind schon mal ins
gespräch gekommen das ist wunderbar und
das gelingt sicherlich auch mit dem
nächsten gast denn es geht darum das
natürlich für die klimawende die
erneuerbaren
ausgebaut werden sollen und das freut
nicht jeden da gibt es auch viel skepsis
leonard schuster ist bei uns auszuruhen
brandenburg erlebt dort und seine
probleme betreffen die genau der ausbau
der windkraft
vielen dank schönen guten abend frau
baerbock ich sitze hier zum einen als
persönlich betroffene zum anderen aber
auch ein stück weit als vertreter von
rund 1000
bürgerinitiativen die sich im ländlichen
raum um windeignungsgebiete herum
gebildet haben ich selber lebe und
arbeite seit 20 jahren in einer
sozialtherapeutischen
lebensgemeinschaft in rohrlack einen
kleinen dorf im land brandenburg
wir betreuen 39 menschen mit
assistenzbedarf geben ihnen ein lebens-
und arbeitsort in unserem dorf gibt es
ein bio bäcker mit kleinen café und
bioladen eine bio gärtnerei ein gestüt
ein walder ein waldkindergarten eine
schul
gründungsinitiative wir haben rund 160
sozialversicherungspflichtige
arbeitsplätze bei rund 160 einwohnern
ein kleines besonderes schönes
funktionierendes lauf wenn wir oleg
verlassen dann sehen wir mais für die
biogasanlagen kartoffeln für die
stärkefabrik raps der im kraftstoff
landet und windräder und jetzt sollen
elf windräder gebaut werden bis auf 1000
meter an unser dorf heran und diese
anlagen sollen 250 meter hoch werden
dass es so groß dass wir das mal in
einer grafik dargestellt haben im
vergleich zu einer unserer dorfkirchen
und zum funkturm und zum fernsehturm auf
dem alexanderplatz 250 meter dass es
unvorstellbar groß und das regelwerk
was die mindestabstände zu wohnsiedlung
bestimmt stammt aus dem jahr 1998
da waren die anlagen maximal 100 meter
hoch der erste fragenkomplex bezieht
sich auf dieses regelwerk warum wird das
nicht den höhen entwicklungen der
anlagen angepasst warum werden die
neuesten medizinischen studien zum
gesundheitsschutz nicht
gesundheitsschutz nicht berücksichtigt
warum sind einrichtungen für
hochsensible menschen wie unsere
bewohnerinnen nicht besonders geschützt
und brandenburg hat jetzt schon eine
unzahl an windrädern in seiner
kulturlandschaft zu stehen und im
nachbardorf liegen jetzt genehmigung für
oder genehmigungsplanung für 14 anlagen
vor dieser größenordnung bauherr sind
die stadtwerke münchen
630 kilometer entfernt bauen bei uns vor
der haustür auf kosten unserer
gesundheit aber auch auf kosten unserer
kulturlandschaft ihr grünes gewissen aus
was können sie da tun oder was haben sie
vor dazu tun um dieses ungleichgewicht
aufzulösen
vielen dank darf man jetzt ganz viele
teilfragen ich nehme mal einzelne heraus
wir können ja dann noch mal auf andere
aspekte mit einstein seit die letzte
frage angefangen
selber in brandenburg leben wir sind in
brandenburg so dass wir fast zwei
prozent der landesfläche für windkraft
nutzen und auch in anderen norddeutschen
und ostdeutschen bundesländern ist viel
windkraft gebaut wurden und im süden des
landes nicht weil es eine politische
entscheidung der großen koalition war zu
sagen wir deckeln erstmal den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien und der windkraft
und vor allen dingen geben wir die
versteigerung so dass es nach
windhöffigkeit geht und deswegen wurde
fiel im norden gebaut und im osten und
nicht im süden das wurde zum glück jetzt
vor einiger zeit sehr korrigiert aber es
bedeutet dass wir massiv im süden und im
westen weiter bauen müssen und was mein
konkreter vorschlag ist deutschlandweit
zwei prozent der landesfläche für
windkraft zu nutzen was bedeutet dass
vor allen dingen im süden und im westen
ordentlich windkraft nachgebaut werden
muss wo wir in brandenburg schon fasste
an dieser zahl sind fragen und
aussteigen wollen brauchen wir
alternative energien die frage ob der
kollege söder und der kollege laschet
damit machen dass die zwei prozent von
ihrem schönen bayern und nordrhein
westfalen für windräder zur verfügung
stehe ich finde dass die tussis große
ungerechtigkeit dass man in bayern sagte
als kollege söder wir haben jetzt zwar
die ganze industrie hier werden auch
atomkraftwerke abgeschaltet aber die
windkraft die wollen wir hier nicht
bauen weil sie abstandsregeln haben
sonderregelung in deutschland dass sie
dort nicht den strom erzeugen und das
ist auch eine frage der gerechtigkeit in
ganz deutschland und deswegen ist mein
vorschlag möchte ich als bundesregierung
dafür sorgen dass wir es im gericht in
deutschland mit zwei prozent der
landesfläche verteilt die leichte
schulter nehmen war ihren einen aspekten
auf jeden fall noch mit nämlich die
frage der anpassung also diese ihre höhe
der wirt der der räder 250 meter muss es
dann nicht auch sofort heißen der
abstand muss vergrößert werden also es
geht ja nach emissionsschutz recht aber
jetzt geht es jetzt hier sehr ins detail
sonst können wir uns danach nochmal
addiert die entfernung beschäftigt viele
welche hat er sich nach vorlage
eingeladen vor zwei monaten ist es
leider wahrscheinlich untergegangen ja
ich war beim anderen wind als
person die im radio gesagt hat das
windrad steht eigentlich viel zu dicht
dann bin ich hingefahren es war
nordrhein-westfalen und dann haben wir
festgestellt dass windkraft steht
eigentlich gut auf abstand und
eigentlich hatte der herr die gleiche
sorge wie sie zu sagen wenn jetzt neue
windräder kommen welcher entfernung ist
es ja eigentlich und das
immissionsschutzrecht was die grundlage
ist bemisst den schattenwurf doom ist
die emissionen und bemisst auch
berücksichtigt wie hoch die anlagen sind
und wenn die alten anlagen 100 meter
hoch waren haben wir 1000 meter abstand
wenn die report werden und jetzt
deutlich höher sind braucht es auch neue
emissionsschutz rechtliche genehmigung
wenn die die gleiche höhe haben dann
bleibt es so wie es ist weil es ist ja
nicht so dass im rechtsfreien raum
gebaut wird sondern dass die frage
emissionsschutz natürlich eine große
rolle spielt sie schüttelt den kopf wenn
ich nur eins ergänzen darf mit blick auf
die gemeinden das ist ja auch was die
gemeinden müssen davon profitieren und
deswegen möchte ich dass die einnahmen
dann nicht in münchen alleine landen wo
der hauptsitz des windanlagenherstellers
oder der stadtwerke ist sondern die
beteiligung in den kommunen ermöglicht
wird was zum beispiel in mecklenburg
vorpommern angegangen wurde und in
brandenburg jetzt ja auch geplant ist
aber wir brauchen kein schmerzensgeld
wir brauchen unsere nachtruhe und ich
brauche schutz für unsere hochs
liebenden bewohner und ich kenne leider
gottes den regionalplan das ist auch so
etwas mit der bürgerbeteiligung so ein
regionalplan hat 450 seiten so eine
genehmigungsplanung 1500 seiten die man
als laie durcharbeiten muss das
emissions- schutzrecht steht ein
bisschen hinter der ta lärm und auf die
wird sich im regionalplan berufen und
die es von 1998 und da haben wir die 100
meter und aber ist bemisst sich nach der
höhe der anlagen ein nein weil die weil
die mission ja berechnet werden wie es
sich dann vor ort auswirkt das rechnen
die sich hin die gesundheits gut
arbeiten meint er sich erst einmal dem
gesundheitsamt achten macht der
betreiber und zum großen teil sind den
unterlagen auch noch geschwärzt und
nicht einsehbar das ist ein riesengroßes
problem wir haben öffentliche verwaltung
die das genehmigen und die natürlich
entsprechend die unterlagen dann auch
prüfen rechnen darf ich ja in
brandenburg bin nach der bundestagswahl
komme ich vorbei dann schauen wir
auf jeden fall mein versprechen herr
schuster das nehmen sie jetzt kommt
darauf zurück so und den zuschauern darf
ich noch sagen weil es ja auch sehr
detailliert wurde wir bieten zu dieser
sendung natürlich auch wieder einen
faktencheck an den wir jetzt geben da
werden dann auch solche detailfragen
noch mal überprüft wir wollen die
diskussion um den klimaschutz weiter
treiben mit paula krüger die nämlich
gekommen ist und sie kommt jetzt
eigentlich aus einer anderen richtung
wenn ich das richtig sehe sie sind
schülerin der frau krüger sie stellen
sich am besten selbst mal vor ja hallo
paula krüger ich bin 18 jahre alt und
bin aus der freien gruppe in der nähe
von bremen aus saerbeck und
meine frage bezieht sich auf das 1,5
grad ziel alle parteien bis auf ein paar
fragwürdige haben gesagt dass sie das
1,5 grad ziel befolgen wollen dass sie
das erreichen werden das programm der
grünen
bezieht sich aber zwar darauf dass die
das 1,5 grad zu erreichen wollen aber
sie werden es nicht schaffen also dass
reicht nicht aus um das ziel zu
erreichen
wie können sie das als klimaschutz
partei verantworten dass sie ein
wahlprogramm aufstellen was das 1,5 grad
ziel nicht befolgen wird
es erst spielerin
in unserem wahlprogramm weil die das
angesprochen haben steht wir werden
alles dafür tun auf diesen 15 grad fahrt
zu kommen ich kann aber nicht
versprechen dass wir in vier jahren
erreicht haben auf dem pfad zu sein das
haben wir gerade an der diskussion
gesehen wir müssen um vor 2030 aus der
kohle auszusteigen weil der strom muss
ja irgendwo herkommen massiv den ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien vorantreiben
deswegen unsere ganz konkreten
vorschläge nicht nur mit blick auf
windkraft auf jedes neue dach eine
solaranlage drauf und vor allen dingen
für die industrie massiv mit blick auf
wasserstoff ermöglichen dass sie auch
klimaneutral produzieren können und
diese weichen müssen jetzt alle in den
nächsten vier jahren gestellt werden und
deswegen habe ich dafür eine klare
haltung zu sagen wir dürfen beim
klimaschutz keine halben sachen mehr
machen sondern dass alles in die wege
leiten und das hat für mich priorität in
der nächsten bundesregierung und dann
warum wir noch nicht auf dem 15 grad
sind ist dass wir mit blick auf die
landwirtschaft zum beispiel wenn wir die
umbauen wollen dass wir in den nächsten
zehn jahren nicht garantieren können
dass wir die klimaneutralität erreicht
haben + wir brauchen internationale
kooperationspartnerschaft und da gehört
für eine ehrliche politik für mich dazu
nicht zu sagen ich verspreche sondern
ich sage wir tun alles was wir in den
nächsten vier jahren tun können um auf
diesen pfaden zu kommen und nutzen dann
die weiteren jahre um mit blick auf die
landwirtschaft und vor allen dingen die
internationale kooperation die nächsten
schritte zu gehen nur wer ist die
alternative ist zu sagen ich rede nur
über das jahr 2045 wieder laschet unter
scholz das tun und sagen nicht was ich
jetzt machen will das ist für mich keine
lösung weil dann werden wir die nächsten
zehn jahre weitermachen und wir sind
erst drei oder vier grad fahrt gerade
danke man sieht schon den einen geht es
zu weit den anderen nicht weit genug
viele aspekte ja und es hat noch jemand
gegeben der sich gemeldet hat herr
kaufmann ihre frage an annalena baerbock
ja schönen guten abend frau berbalk da
ist kaufmann ich komme vom bodensee
geboren bin ich in berlin hier
aufgewachsen das heißt ich kenne beide
seiten das landleben und der stadt leben
nächstes jahr sollen die spritpreise
drastisch ansteigen und das macht mir
angst das macht mir angst
insofern dass ich befürchte das
ehrenamt verschwindet kinder und
jugendsport in den verein kaputt geht
weil die eltern es nicht sich leisten
können ihre kinder mehrmals die woche in
den weiteren patersdorf zum sport zu
bringen ich selber bin trainer
trainieren handball ich werde aufhören
wenn der trainer spricht der liter sprit
zwei euro kostet wir haben relativ
schlecht ausgebautes öffentliches
verkehrsnetz wie wollen sie gleichzeitig
mit der spritpreiserhöhung dafür sorgen
dass wir auch auf dem land öffentliche
verkehrsmittel zur verfügung haben
doch mal unterschiedliche punkte in der
frage verkehrten normal mit der
spritpreis regierung nicht nächstes jahr
wird der spritpreis um 16 cent erhöht
das kommt in der öffentlichen diskussion
gerade auch in der
medienberichterstattung manchmal ein
bisschen durcheinander sondern über die
nächsten jahre und sie wissen glaube ich
alle schlagen co2 preis vorgeschlagen
energie geld vor ich würde nur gerne
einmal ganz anderen aspekt mit rainer
wie viel ist es denn im nächsten jahr
also wenn sicherlich rechts an sind also
wir tanken am bodensee zwischen 180
liter ja in 70 städten und 155 in
überlingen
180 den liter aber auf den punkt wollte
ich gerade mal eingehen wenn sie mich da
einmal vielleicht zwei minuten erklären
lassen weil eine minute es ist es ist so
eine große gesellschaftliche aufgabe und
sie haben ja gesagt die tanken zwischen
1 80 und 1 55 wir haben also jetzt schon
preisschwankungen beim benzinpreis von
25 cent die haben nichts mit klimaschutz
zu tun die haben damit zu tun dass die
öl förderstaaten im zweifel sei jetzt
wird es der ölpreis mit eurer oder wenn
ferien sind erhöhen alle tankstellen
auch noch mal ordentlich also die 155
sind wenn man sucht auf dem handy und
wenn man die richtige zeit ab ortet also
nicht generell in der regel sind es 170
ich möchte an dieser stelle deutlich
machen dass die großen preisschwankungen
die wir auch in der vergangenheit erlebt
haben nicht klimaschutz bedingt waren
sondern aus anderen faktor und
nichtsdestotrotz ich bin selber auf dem
land groß geworden ich weiß da braucht
man das auto das heißt deswegen dass wir
die 16 cent über die nächsten jahre
erhöhen wollen um deutlich zu machen wir
brauchen ein umstieg auf saubere autos
und das heißt zugleich diejenigen die
nicht soviel geld haben die zu
unterstützen auf elektroautos zu
wechseln mit einer kaufpreis prämie von
9000 euro und den öffentlichen
nahverkehr auszubauen dass in ländlichen
regionen jede stunde der bus kommt und
vor allen dingen bahnstrecken
reaktiviert werden sind viele facetten
die wir brauchen auf dem weg zur
klimaneutralität weil ansonsten sagen
unsere kinder unsere enkel wie konntet
ihr es zulassen dass ihr 20 jahre lang
nichts getan aber die sorge ist herr
kaufmann wenn ich sie richtig verstehe
die preise für den sprit steigen
schneller als das angebot für den
öffentlichen nahverkehr kommt natürlich
ja dass das problem ist ich fahre ich
habe arbeitsweg 14 kilometer direkt berg
und tal nicht arbeiten weil hausen im
hafen und nordhafen meister ich würde
gerne mit der bahn fahren oder mit bus
wissen sie wie ich fahren muss ich habe
mein arbeitsweg nämlich mit dem
busfahrer mit zwei
nahverkehrsbetrieben und ungefähr zwei
stunden fahrzeit findet direkt strecke
von 14 kilometern meine frau geht es
ähnlich die haben einfach keine
busverbindung dahin ja wenn eine frau
bei uns aus dem ort anlegerin nach
göttingen fahren wir zum einkaufen was
macht die bei 30 grad seien fertig mit
dem bus jede stunde fährt und dann
verpasst du dir nur vor rückweg mit
tiefkühl sachen etage wartete eine
stunde bei 30 watt im sommer sind
gespalten genauso jetzt kauft sich diese
oma aber sicher kein auto mehr
so das kommt drauf an was sie planen wie
lange sie noch auto fährt also
nochmal erst einmal einer stelle jeder
kann jetzt ein gebrauchtes auto
weiterfahren wie er will und jeder kann
auch weiter auf dem land fahren wie
gesagt es braucht auf dem land auch
weiter automobil verkehrt die frage ist
ja nur ändern wir jetzt was an dem
system das wir in schlechten
öffentlichen nahverkehr haben
nehmen wir jetzt geld in die hand und
das will ich zu sagen wir widmen jetzt
um damit zum beispiel auch die
ticketpreise wenn sie
landkreisübergreifend fahren sich
dreimal so teuer sind als wenn sie mit
dem auto fahren oder lassen wir alles
wie bisher und dann mal glaube wir
sollten ein paar zentrale dinge ändern
nicht nur für den klimaschutz sondern
dass auf dem land alle mobil sind weil
es hat auch nicht jeder ein führerschein
das heißt der öffentliche nahverkehr
muss dringend ausdrücklich hoffmann ich
glaube wir müssen noch ein bisschen
weiter kommen vielen dank war
und bittere fragile glaube ich hier
wahrscheinlich müssen sie jetzt auch
noch mal nach radolfzell fahren dass das
fortzusetzen
so frau bleibt auch in dieser klartext
sendung wollen wir nicht nur die gäste
hier bei uns im studio zu wort kommen
lassen sondern auch stimmen von außen
hören die wir in den letzten wochen quer
durch die republik eingefangen haben
kurze fragen und mit der bitte um
möglichst kurze antworten hören was uns
jetzt mal an die erste frau bernburg
ernähren sie sich eigentlich vegan
kurze antwort nein nein und vegetarisch
auch nicht also gemischt ok zweite frage
wie überzeuge ich die eltern auch die
ältere generation davon dass die grünen
ziele wichtig sind
in dem man viel mit seiner oma sein opa
seinen eltern spricht wobei ich auch
viele viele ältere menschen gerade auch
wieder im ländlichen raum war letztens
vor ort meinte eine rentnerin zu mir
meine güte das ist hier der badesee wo
ich immer als jugendliche rhein
gesprungen bin jetzt ist der steg so
dass er ins trockene führt hier ist so
viel passiert in den letzten jahren
durch
grundwasserabsenkung aber auch durch
klimawandel das heißt dass viele gerade
ältere ja auch sagen wir müssen jetzt
beim klimaschutz dringend was tun aber
viel diskutieren als junge generation
weil es wählen hat deutlich mehr ältere
in unserem land als junger menschen so
und das dritte wie können sie allen
geschönten lebenslauf abgeben und so tun
als ob nichts gewesen wäre
ich habe bei meinem lebenslauf
unterschiedliche mitgliedschaften
angegeben und das nicht das aktualisiert
gehabt sondern es unter eine sammel
rubrik gestellt mitgliedschaften und zum
beispiel bei greenpeace ist man kein
mitglied sondern fördermitglied und das
habe ich dann entsprechend korrigiert
aber der lebenslauf auch das buch das
viele zitate hatte ohne quellenangabe
hat ja am jedenfalls in der anfangsphase
des wahlkampfs ihrer glaubwürdigkeit
geschadet ich will einmal nachfragen was
war da eigentlich die motivation frau
berbalk hatten sie das gefühl sie müssen
sich vielleicht dauert relativ junge
kanzlerkandidatin bisschen bedeutender
machen nein nein sondern ich habe also
mit blick auf das buch ein buch
geschrieben wie wir dieses land erneuern
mit vielen vielen ideen die ich in den
letzten jahren gelesen gehört habe mir
notizen gemacht habe und das alles in
das buch mit integriert und deutlich
gemacht wie wir deutschland verändern
können und hätte an den stellen deutlich
machen müssen von wem diese idee mit
gekommen ist und dass überarbeitet jetzt
gründlich weil das war ein großer fehler
robert bork vielleicht fragen sich auch
viele wodurch fühlen sie sich eigentlich
auf dieses wichtige amt auf das
kanzleramt vorbereitet wenn man mal
durch die geschichte der bundesrepublik
geht und von adenauer absieht alle
anderen acht kanzler waren es insgesamt
waren vor entweder ministerpräsident
oder ministerin also wo durchführen sie
sich vorbereitet
dadurch dass ich eine klare vision habe
wie wir deutschland erneuern können und
vor allem die kraft die veränderung
anzupacken weil wir erlebt haben durch
die regierungserfahrung die manch andere
über 20 jahre haben dass wir in vielen
großen zukunftsfragen in der sackgasse
geraten sind das ist nicht nur der
klimaschutz das ist die digitalisierung
und auch der zustand der schulen in
unserem land und ich bin seit acht
jahren im bundestag und führe seit
dreieinhalb jahren eine der größten
parteien in deutschland und ich glaube
es braucht jetzt einen wirklichen
aufbruch und wir sehen in anderen
ländern dass wenn eine andere generation
von politikerin antritt mit weniger
regierungserfahrung dass das auch in
neuen aufbruch schaffen kann das ist
mein angebot so der wahl so ein kleiner
exkurs was nun frau bärbel weiter geht
es in zwei minuten
wir reden über die wichtigsten themen
dieses wahlkampfs in dieser klartext
sendung und natürlich gehört das thema
corona dazu und im nächsten film
begegnen wir einer frau die sich um
migranten kümmert in dieser corona krise
und die sagt gerade für die frauen die
ich betreue war die pandemie eine art
weckruf
familienhelferin jehan kodré bringt
geflüchteten frauen in wattenscheid
deutschbein in kleingruppen wegen corona
dreimal pro woche gibt es das sprach-
und spielcafé der bedarf aber ist viel
größer schweren herzens muss sie immer
wieder frauen wegschicken
isoliert jetzt noch mehr und die haben
das von eingesehen die müssen an sich
arbeiten und die müssen auch lernen
verständigungsprobleme beim arzt die
kinder ohne unterstützung im
homeschooling für viele geflüchtete war
corona wie ein turbo deutsch zu lernen
und sich zu integrieren
die haben hoffnung für eine besseres
leben wir wollen auch nicht nur hartz 4
empfänger seien sondern die von auch
lernen nicht nur auch für deren kinder
sondern die sind auch selber noch jung
wir können noch arbeiten sie hat er
selbst kam als kleines mädchen aus dem
libanon hierher hat sich in deutschland
durchgebissen ausgerechnet in corona
lockt da und sagt sie habe sich eine tür
geöffnet für mehr integration
viele familien wollen in deutschland
besser klarkommen das land verstehen und
seine sprache deswegen seien fachkräfte
wie sie so wichtig bei eltern bei
erwachsenen migranten muss bildung groß
geschrieben werden da brauchen wir große
unterstützung von regierung und vom
politik denn nach wie vor gebe es viel
zu wenig angebote und viel zu wenig
personal lehrer erzieher sozialarbeiter
und sie ist ja bei uns vorbei auch wenn
sie sich und frauke was ist ihre frage
an frau werbung ja guten abend grüner
hat vieles sichtbar gemacht sehr sehr
viel sichtbar gemacht und wir wissen
mehr an welchen punkten wir arbeiten
müssen gemeinsam arbeiten müssen und
viele migranten sind sehr motiviert die
wollen lernen und die sind jetzt
lernfähig meine frage ist
welche
bildungsstrategie haben sie für
migranten geplant
erst mal vielen dank nicht nur für die
frage
sondern für das tolle engagement was wir
auch im film gesehen haben das sieht man
in vielen stadtteilen das genau die
frage mit blick auf corona
stadtteilarbeit noch mal verstärkt hat
weil die gesundheitsvorsorge gespräch
über gesundheit in den stadtteil
betrieben wird und was kann man tun sie
haben es selber im beitrag ja schon
angesprochen die finanziellen mittel für
stadtteilarbeit für soziale arbeit für
integrationskurse
verstetigen wir hatten in den letzten
jahren von der bundesregierung viele
mittel für integration die werden jetzt
schrittweise zurückgefahren ich halte
das für falsch ich will die dauerhafte
finanzieren weil deutsch lernen wie sie
auch deutlich gemacht haben ist der
schlüssel zur integration zur teilhabe
am arbeitsleben und der zweite bereich
mit kinder und jugendliche bildung ist
es a und o dass alle nur faire chance
haben und das heißt für mich und das ist
mein angebot als bundeskanzlerin in
diesem land zu sagen für den bund gilt
auch dass er in die bildungsfinanzierung
mit einsteigen muss gerade in den
grundschulen das sind alle kinder
zusammen egal welcher herkunft ob zu
hause deutsch gesprochen wird welches
einkommen und da brauchen wir eine
verlässliche finanzierung gerade für die
schulen was ihr auch angesprochen hatten
um mehr als 20 prozent der kinder sind
die unterstützung brauchen durch
sozialpädagogen durch weitere lehrkräfte
und vor allen dingen angebote sport
musik gartenarbeit auch dann im
nachmittagsprogramm an dieser stelle
möchte ich mich auch im namen von vielen
flüchtlinge und migranten an vier
vereine gedanken in nordrhein westfalen
das ist der weiße ring humanitäre
solidarität ist und sozialer dsk durch
frauen und männer und progressiver
elternverband die haben familien
unterstützt finanziell unterstützt durch
sachspenden seelsorger waren die und
bildungsangebote haben die viel
unterstützt in dieser zeit also dass ein
großer respekt vielen dank den dank
nehmen wir noch gerne mit
beim thema coruna und kinder schüler das
fordert sicherlich noch manchen heraus
sich zu melden ich weiß dass wir ein
lehrer aus hessen dabei haben ich glaube
das ist der herr hartmann lucia hat man
wenn sie ihre frage vom ja gerne mein
name ist guido hartmann ich bin 44 jahre
und seit 18 jahren einer kooperativen
gesamtschulen die zu machen also den
südlich von frankfurt und wir haben in
den letzten eineinhalb jahren ein
ziemliches chaos an schule gehabt das
lag zum einen daran denke ich dass alle
unsere erste pandemie war man sich darin
finden wir haben denke ich aber an
schulen ganz guten weg gefunden wie wir
das machen können wir haben aber dann
immer und immer wieder unsere konzepte
beim haufen werfen müssen und zwar nicht
weil wir das wollten sondern weil wir
und das hat sich eigentlich dann immer
so fortgesetzt fighters aus der presse
erfahren haben was wir am montag
umzusetzen haben und das hat nicht nur
uns lehrkräfte total zu mir weil wir
immer und immer wieder neu anfangen
mussten zu planen und planung von
bildung funktioniert nicht innerhalb von
zwei drei vier tagen das ist ein
langfristiges projekt da muss ich ein
bisschen zeit dran ich muss da
tatsächlich auch eine strategie hinter
haben wie möchte ich meinen schülern was
beibringen und das ist natürlich meinem
chef geht's genauso der muss gucken wie
jetzt setzt sich 100-150 lehrkräfte ein
damit das passt damit alle schüler dass
er sich auch die fächer bekommen die wir
ihnen zustehen und das hat nicht nur die
lehrkräfte sehr mürbe gemacht ich denke
auch die eltern und die kinder und wir
haben einige von diesen kindern
tatsächlich auch trotz aller bemühungen
verloren weil wir dem nicht gerecht
werden konnten oder sind vor allem die
kinder die wir verlieren die es am
dringendsten nötig haben die jüngsten
angewiesen sind weil ihre eltern eben
nicht das ersetzen können was wir ja
schon nicht bieten konnten und meine
frage ist wie schaffen wir dass die
länder die bundesländer aber eben auch
die schulträger also sprich die
landkreise und die kreisfreien städte
dazu zu bringen endlich genug geld in
die hand zu nehmen wenn der kräftemangel
die 44 milliarden für gebäude die an die
schule sind marode muss ganz ganz
dringend investiert werden oder auch nur
luftfilter nach 18 monaten pandemie gibt
es den allermeisten klassenräume noch
keine luftfilter und das sind gerade
fünf bis 14 jährigen die momentan weil
sie noch nicht geimpft werden können
besonders anfällig sind oder die nicht
geschützt werden und da wird mir ganz
ganz anders und ich werde als lehrkraft
fühle mich tatsächlich kannten spieler
nicht gerecht werden wie kriegen wir das
hin die länder dazu zu bringen endlich
das geld in die hand zu nehmen was
notwendig ist
an der stelle verlieren gerade danke
gesagt auch mein herzlicher dank an
diejenigen die als lehrkräfte als
sozialarbeiter in dem anime alles
gegeben haben um ältere aber auch kinder
durch die pandemie zu bringen und all
das was sie beschrieben haben nicht als
spitzenpolitikerin sondern als mutter
habe ich ganz vieles selber erlebt von
zwei jetzt grundschulkindern und wie
kriegen wir es dazu dass es in zukunft
besser wird in dem nicht alle sagen
bildung hat priorität und dann
investieren wir nicht rein und deswegen
will ich dass wir eine richtige
veränderung haben dass der bund das war
ja das hauptproblem ich habe das immer
wieder angesprochen auch im bundestag
auch gegenüber den anderen beiden
parteien zu sagen wir müssen die
priorität auf bildung liegen und dann
hieß es von der bundesregierung der bund
ist dafür aber nicht zuständig ich halte
das für falsch und ich will dass der
bund in die verantwortung geht weil mit
blick auf die frage gelder an den
schulen wir brauchen einfach eine
verlässliche finanzierung in allen
schulen und nicht wenn eine kommune
reich ist dann kann sie die maßnahmen
machen und wenn eine kommune weniger
geld hat dann kann sie es nicht machen
und deswegen braucht eine dauerhafte
finanzierung und nicht diese
fördermittel die projektweise sind auf
drei jahre angelegt welcher
sozialpädagoge fängt an wenn nach drei
jahren wie fördermittel wieder weg sind
und dass eine verlässliche finanzierung
der grundschule ist für mich die
priorität das angebot was ich mache für
die nächste bundesregierung das klingt
schon mal ziemlich gut man muss aber
sagen es ja auch so dass diese diese
einmal finanzierung häufig einfach
daneben geht wir haben jetzt pandemie
gerät bekommen also keine tablets die
wir einsetzen sollen die haben einen
ganzen haufen geld gekostet die können
wir aber nicht einsetzen weil eben das
langfristige der support nicht
finanziert wird und dementsprechend
dürfen mit den geräten fast nichts
anfangen weil unser schulträger die
angeschafft hat angst es könnte kaputt
gehen und also eine normale lern app zu
installieren ist ein riesenmarkt und
dann macht das keiner mehr ja und das
ist tatsächlich ein geld das hätte man
anderswo besser einsetzen können aber
jetzt ist es so dass ist nach hat das
kooperationsverbot dass sie angesprochen
haben das ist ja eine
verfassungsgeschichte da braucht man
zwei drittel mehrheit und wenn wir das
nicht hinkriegen wie schaffen wir es
denn dann die länder in die pflicht zu
nehmen und wie ist das mit der
schuldenbremse ist das wirklich
generationengerecht oder dass er eine
bildungsprämie momentan
schuldenbremse klaus zwar zweiter
beitrag also die frage ist haltung in
einer politischen entscheidung was sie
angesprochen haben mit dem
digitalgeräten das war vollkommen klar
dass das passiert wenn man erst zwanzig
seiten formulare und die ganze kommune
muss mitmachen daher hatte ich klar
gesagt die schulen müssen im budget
bekommen und davon können sie dann die
digitalen geräte
kaufen beantragen damit es auch
umgesetzt wird das gleiche mit den
luftfiltern die als anderthalb jahre zu
spät gekommen das ist ja ein bisschen
jetzt vergossene milch nach vorne
gewandt ja man kann sagen wir brauchen
eine zweidrittelmehrheit
grundgesetzänderung man kann es aber
auch anders machen bildung als
sozialpolitische aufgabe verstehen und
so sehe ich das wenn jedes kind das
gleiche recht haben soll gut zur schule
zu gehen in der ersten klasse sind alle
kinder da das ist eine riesenchance die
erreichen jedes kind und das ist für
mich eine sozialpolitische maßnahmen und
deswegen wie finanziert man dass ich
will dass über das sozialgesetzbuch
finanzieren als teilaufgabe von sozialen
aufgaben mit blick auf
entwicklungschancen für kinder und wenn
man ans grundgesetz rangehen dann nicht
nur an die frage bildungsföderalismus
sondern auch kinderrechte endlich ins
grundgesetz zu schreiben bei kinder sind
keine kleinen erwachsenen
und das ist eine der wichtigen lehrern
für mich aufs corona endlich die rechte
von kindern in unserem land
sicherzustellen
er hat man das hat noch mal zur
konkretisierung geführt vielen dank für
ihre zweite frage auch und wir bleiben
noch beim thema corinna frau bärbel das
ganze ist noch nicht gebannt die vierte
welle rollt und es gibt auch natürlich
langzeitfolgen etwa die longo wird
patienten das ausmaß kennt man noch gar
nicht richtig die dimension thomas
thelen ist zu uns gekommen er sitzt
glaube ich dort hinter ihnen aus
leverkusen und hätten danke dass sie
gekommen sind denn das ist anstrengend
für sie sie sind ein longo witt patient
und sie kommen aber auch hier mit
konkreten fragen bitte schön
für mich geht es darum dass ich heute ja
wo zuletzt der ärztezeitung 350.000 bis
500 menschen hier vertreten darf
vermutlich sind eine million menschen
potenzielle wähler
ich möchte mal kurz zu erzählen wie das
leben das logo wird der kranken aussieht
wir waren in einer welle der ersten
erkrankung ich bin mehr 2020 erkrankt
und
zum anfang war es so dass wir die
intensivpatienten
gut bedient wurden kamen bildung kurve
patienten auf die tagesordnung und dann
fing es an dass wir alle gesagt haben
okay ist das jetzt systematisch wir sind
von arzt zu arzt gerannt und keiner
kommt uns helfen viele patienten sind
heute noch auf den ländlichen bereich so
weit dass es immer noch soweit heißt ja
das ist dennoch gut das gibt es ja gar
nicht
es ist so dass beispielsweise
reha maßnahmen abgelehnt werden
persönlich beispiel meine letzte realist
abgelehnt wurden vor 16 wochen von der
rentenkasse mit der begründung posco
wird stellt keine erkrankungen oder
keine schwere erkrankung sind einer
erwerbsminderung für da ich bin
unternehmer ich arbeite seit letzten
also seit märz 2020 nicht vom
krankengeld kann man nicht leben
parallel dazu ist man kommt zu den
ambulanzen die aufgebaut wurden aber die
ambulanzen haben uns nur gefragt wir
haben keine antworten bekommen keine
keine kritik an die ärzte aber laut
aktueller information wenn fünf
millionen investierten longo mit
forschung was den fünf millionen gar
nichts und da erwarte ich einfach nicht
nur wenn es um medikamente wbc 007 geht
all das worauf wir uns stützen und
worauf wir so viel hoffnung setzen bitte
helfen sie uns was was sind ihre
konkreten vorschläge
also erstmal wichtig dass wir dieses
thema in der sendung kamen und dass sie
das auch noch mal deutlich beschreiben
weil in ganz vielen bereichen wie sie
gesagt haben sind wir wissenschaftlich
noch gar nicht so weit dass wir wissen
was hat das alles für langzeitschäden
oder wenn real möglichkeiten abgelehnt
werden das öffentlich zu machen und zu
diskutieren wie kann das sein
in anderen bereichen gibt es ja jetzt
reha möglichkeiten also ich kenne von
anderen wo genau das genehmigte wurde
ich muss es selber bezahlen ja genau und
dass das ist was das kann nicht sein
sondern das jetzt deutlich zu machen das
ist eine erkrankung um die wir uns als
gesellschaft und damit auch im
öffentlichen raum kümmern müssen diese
reihe möglichkeiten weiter auszubauen zu
finanzieren für all diejenigen die an
grippe erkrankt sind in den
forschungsbereich deutlich mehr zu
investieren weil wir auch noch nicht
wissen das bedeutet es jetzt mit wenn
möglicherweise eine weitere welle kommt
wie ist das nun mit der dritten impfung
deswegen kann ich einfach nur das was
sie gesagt haben unterstreichen das sind
die maßnahmen die wir jetzt tun müssen
und noch mit anfügen alle müssen sich
impfen lassen wenn sie das hier noch mal
beschreiben wie die folgeschäden auch
sind die folge einschränkung auch sind
wir müssen dazu kommen dass deutlich
über 80 prozent in der bevölkerung
geimpft werden damit wir diese pandemie
in den griff bekommen für die kinder
aber auch für menschen wie sie die
betroffenen sind damit wir das anderen
menschen dieses leid ersparen das ist
richtig impfung ist ein wichtiger punkt
trotz alledem geht es hier war ja auch
noch um den punkt der dahinter kommt wir
alle wissen ja gar nicht auch weil es um
erwerbsminderung geht ganz viele kämpfen
darum immer noch dass es als arbeits
erkrankung
angemeldet wird das anerkannt wird ja da
sind krankenschwestern und pfleger bei
uns in der longo witt gruppe die waren
in der ersten welle an dem die menschen
haben applaudiert an der straße aber die
menschen sind jetzt krank und und
kämpfen darum dass das anerkannt wird
weil die haben für uns gekämpft
gleichzeitig in meinem fall ja gut ich
kann jetzt wieder lesen und schreiben
nur mal so in den raum gestellt ich bin
unternehmer wissen sie was das bedeutet
wenn man nicht mehr lesen und schreiben
kann wenn man kaum in der lage ist drei
vier stufen zu gehen das ist wahnsinn ja
und vielleicht dann auch noch eine
weitere frage sie haben daher auch
durchaus negative erfahrung mit sozialen
medien gemacht und wieder so soll ich
jetzt mal durchaus stimmung gemacht wird
diejenigen von uns lang oder kranken
sich getraut haben vor die kamera zu
gehen und zu sagen das ist die
erkrankung in meinem fall habe ich meine
familie sogar mit vor die kamera
genommen und zu sagen mensch hier das
bedeutet mehr das bin ich nur ich als
erkrankter das ist denn die leute
drumherum was sagen sie den querdenkern
die uns leute noch beschimpfen als
simulanten als als wirklich schlimme
worte die uns dahingegen gebracht werden
das ist schrecklich und was sagen sie
den querdenkern das ist in der
potenzielle wähler
deutsche bürger
die erlebe ich aufhöre jeder meiner
öffentliche auftritte weil genau mit dem
was ich jetzt in diesen tagen immer
wieder deutlich gemacht habe wir müssen
nicht mit blick auf impfen nur dafür
sorgen dass die impf angebote überall
hinkommen sondern auch mit blick auf
zweig regelungen damit wir verhindern
dass krankenhäuser weiter kollabieren
eine klare haltung zu haben auch vor der
wahl wir müssen in den hot spot zweig
einführen kommt ganz ganz viele von
denjenigen auf die veranstaltung mit
trillerpfeifen und ich halte klar
dagegen weil ich bin davon überzeugt wir
müssen in so einer situation auch wie
sie sagen von der bundestagswahl sehr
deutlich machen was ist eine gefahr für
unsere gesamte gesellschaft und das ist
dass dieses virus sich in den herbst
wieder weiter ausbreitet und deswegen
impfen impfen impfen klare kante aber
ich möchte auch dann noch mal sagen sie
haben sehr deutlich gemacht was das für
die familie für sie bedeutet was es für
sie bedeutet lassen sie uns damit
zukünftig sind
dass kalinka sprechen und auch
parteiübergreifend karl lauterbach zum
beispiel als einer der sich auch immer
wieder hingestellt hat in solchen
momenten auch überparteilich
zusammenzustehen und deutlich zu machen
dass ist eine pandemie die wir nur als
gesellschaft bekämpfen können und danke
dass sie trotzdem auch wenn sie sagen
sie haben so viele anfeindungen die
kraft haben das weiter in den
öffentlichen raum zu tragen ich kann ihn
zu sichern sie sind nicht allein sein
wunsch auch in der bundesregierung werde
ich das öffentliche weiter vorne
gesprungen dankeschön ja wir wollen doch
alle das versteck bitte gestimmt kürzer
weil die zeit rennt uns schon weg zu
weit zu wort kommen lassen ist es
nochmal unternehmer sie sind aktiv aber
sie können nicht so arbeiten wie sie es
eigentlich wollen ihre frage an frau war
also ich mein name ist es nicht geht ich
bin
betreiber eines klubs eines musik clubs
in frankfurt bin auch dj und wir haben
ja jetzt bald die 2g regelungen zum
bundesland das ja auch
schwarz-grün regiert wird und wir haben
halt das problem glaube ich alle
betreiber dass wir mit dieser zweig
regelung vor großen problemen stehen
einmal werden wir wie sie es auch schon
aus dem social media bereich kennen
wahrscheinlich einen shitstorm erwarten
das bleibt nicht aus das sehen wir schon
in anderen städten wo es zweig schon
gibt und wir haben natürlich auch das
problem dass wir die gesellschaft
spalten und das quasi der impfzwang auf
unserem rücken ausgetragen wird ich bin
selbst geimpft ich bin kein gegner sagt
vielleicht als wunder aber ich finde
dass wir die leute und die gesellschaft
zu spalten können was das ergebnis davon
es ist diese menschen die werden nicht
zu hause sitzen die werden die
städtischen tränen weil sie jetzt nicht
in club reinkommen nie während woanders
treffen wenn es illegal treffen so wie
es jetzt die ganze zeit war in hamburg
in frankfurt in münchen in stuttgart in
köln wo wir es über alltours haben
glaubt es angekommen und durch die
illegalen partys haben wir in vier
kurzen infektions vorkommen also
irgendwas muss geändert werden zweig
kann nicht die regel sein
ich sehe das anders habe ich ja gerade
als antwort auch getan weil auch hier
ist wieder die frage wenn wir nichts tun
dann rauschen wir in einen herbst das
ist nichtstun zweig auf dem rücken der
gastronom ist nichts tun sie dazu sie
setzen sich alle für das impfen ein dann
fahren sie als politiker den impfzwang
dann bekennen sie farbe und sagen okay
dann machen wir den impfzwang anziehen
was durch aber da scheitert bei den
politikern momentan und wir haben das
problem dass wir dargestellt werden wie
dass wir die leute zum impfen zwingen
wollen was ja ganz scharf all das also
dass auch frau überhaupt mal ausreden
bitte an dem punkt ja nun also für mich
ist der punkt wir können nicht mit
ansehen dass schulen wieder komplett
geschlossen werden oder dass noch mehr
menschen erkranken und krankenhäuser
komplett überlaufen deswegen ist es
nicht nur zwei gs ist impfen überall in
jeden stadtteil in jedes quartier vor
jeder bildungseinrichtung an jedem
arbeitsplatz zu bringen dass menschen
sich impfen lassen aber mit blick auf
die 2g regelung wir haben gesehen wie
sich das virus weiter verbreitet wenn
und es sind ja wahnsinnig viele menschen
geimpft die dann entsprechend in die
clubs in die restaurants gehen können
chronisch kranke ausgenommen kinder die
nicht geimpft werden können ausgenommen
und das dann zu ermöglichen dass
diejenigen die sich solidarisch zeigen
in einer gesellschaft indem sie andere
schützen auch ihre freiheit wieder haben
können und diejenigen die sagen das ist
das freie recht und deswegen ist es kein
impfzwang das können wir in deutschland
so nicht umsetzen aber die sagen ich bin
nicht solidarisch können nicht erwarten
dass alle anderen auf ihre freiheiten
verzichten und kinder nicht mehr zur
schule gehen können und das was mit
blick auf finanzielle einbußen dann für
gastronomen für kulturschaffende im
zweifel da ist das haben wir auch im
blick auf das letzte jahr gesehen dann
braucht es eine finanzielle
unterstützung aber nochmal in so nen
lockdown reinzurutschen nochmal kinder
anderthalb jahre zu hause lassen das
geht nicht und das heißt für mich
verantwortungsvolle politik und deswegen
sage ich das auch so klar und deutlich
vor der bundestagswahl weil ich will
nicht dass im oktober alle wieder sagen
hätten wir mal gehandelt schon jetzt ist
erschwert sie wollen weiter vielleicht
mal was nach der sendung freiburg vielen
dank
ja wir haben bei herrn spät das wort
spaltung gehört und corona hat die
gräben im land durchaus aktiv wir wollen
uns jetzt nochmal mit der frage
beschäftigen wie leben wir zusammen in
diesem land trotz vieler spannungen
stadt gegen land wo sich mancher
abgehängt für das ist auch so ein
konflikt und unser nächster gast fragt
sich ob die grünen dafür eine lösung
haben
uwe rahn drehens ist ortsvorsteher in
sachsendorf in brandenburg 32 jahre nach
der wende gibt es hier vor allem eins
stillstand der alte konsum schon lange
dicht und auch sonst ist in dem
beschaulichen dorf nahe der polnischen
grenze fast nichts geblieben wir stehen
hier vom konsum wir hatten dort drüben
war eine bibliothek wir hatten den arzt
der haus wir hatten einen friseur
wir hatten die 60 geschäfte hero guitar
wir hatten eine schule
die leute sind einfach frustriert weil
nach 30 jahren wenn du nichts groß
passiert ist blühende landschaften
versprochen ja die sehen wir potsdam
berlin fahren sehen sie steht wunderbare
verfahren entstanden der ländliche raum
wo er über jahrzehnte einfach
vernachlässigt die landstraße sich mal
geflickt wie zu ddr zeiten hier fährt
nur der schulbus in den ferien gar kein
bus dann müssten unsere bürgerinnen und
bürger sich mal wieder in den 10
kilometer entfernte kreisstadt kommen
enttäuschung
ärger als ortsvorsteher muss er viel
aushalten 40 prozent haben hier bei der
landtagswahl hfd gewählt das ist was die
leute hier eben verärgert und im
umstimmt und denn eben bei der wahl
umtreibt und gewisse parteien wählt
weise sagen wir sind einfach enttäuscht
von dem was die letzten jahre passiert
ist
ein fdp kandidat hatte sich als
ortsvorsteher aufgestellt andreas
zögerte nicht lange bewarb sich und
wurde gewählt er will so viel wie
möglich für die menschen hier tun doch
ohne die hilfe aus berlin gibt es nicht
sie übernehmen verantwortung für ihren
ort sachsendorf und sie haben eine frage
erst mal schönen abend vor der burg
kurzen nebenbei ich komme aus dem
oderbruch und ich würde sie gerne mal
dort einladen wo sie letztes waren das
war nicht das urlaub ja richtig sie
haben sie am film gesehen der ländliche
raum stellen sie sich nur im osten soll
es auch einen teil im westen so aber wir
kommen aus einer anderen geschichte da
war schon nicht viel und die menschen
haben sie was erhofft nach der wende
dass da was passiert und 30 jahre ist
prinzip nichts passiert wir hatten
gerade den rändern mit den benzinpreisen
also alles nur auf die ölproduzenten zu
china also die kann abholen fahne zehn
hektar beteiligen euro für sprit und
hier bezahlung ins 80 also kann es ja
nicht nur an den produzenten des öls
liegen was wollen sie als grüne tun wenn
ich jetzt ihr wahlplakat sehe co2 steuer
erhöhen benzinpreise hin wem trifft dass
das betrifft die landbevölkerung die
ihrer regel im industry sektor arbeitet
also die keine spitzenverdiener sind die
30 40 80 kilometer zur arbeit fahren
müssen nicht nur alleine die frau der
man wenn sie zwei jugendliche kinder
haben 18 19 brauchen die auch ein auto
da wird ein preiswertes auto
diese möglichkeit besteht ja gar nicht
wenn sie sagen ab 2030 werden die
verbrenner verboten wie soll sich eine
vierköpfige familie die weit verstreut
in brandenburg arbeiten geht das noch
finanzieren neue heizungsanlagen dann
wollen sie den leuten verpflichten ein
solardach
auszusetzen ja wer finanziertes solar
müssen dieses selber war die kredite
finanzieren finanziert es der staat
warum soll ich auf meinem dach jetzt für
die allgemeinen solar darauf machen
welche selber finanzieren muss das sind
alles fragen die die leute um stimmt
verärgert und von den grünen keine
antworten sehen wir sehen nur die
preiserhöhung aber was steckt dahinter
noch wahr wie wollen sie sich einsetzen
will dass ländlichen lebensraum
an zwei punkten nur dass es korrekt ist
ölpreis das natürlich nicht nur der
einzige punkt sondern in deutschland
haben wir schon auch jetzt steuern auf
den benzinpreis drauf und ab 2030 jeder
kann sein gebrauchtes auto weiterfahren
geht um neue autos die neu zugelassen
werden und die solaranlagen auch auf
neue dächer und auf ihr keine
solaranlage aber ihre frage ist eine
berechtigte frage was machen wir in den
ländlichen regionen haben wir gerade
gesehen ist aber auch sehr
unterschiedlich in brandenburg werden
gerade urlaub mit einem anderen ort wo
es wo es viele angebote gibt aber im
grundgesetz steht gleichwertige
lebensverhältnisse und deswegen kann ich
den frust auch total verstehen wir haben
nicht überall gleichwertige
lebensverhältnisse vor allen dingen in
strukturschwächeren regionen und was
will ich tun
zusätzlich gelder auflegen vom bund als
gemeinschaftsaufgabe für
strukturschwache ländliche räume wo wir
strecken wieder aktivieren bei ihnen
weiß wahrscheinlich jetzt kein kein
bahnhof gewesen die haben aber andere
strecken in brandenburg da steht ein
bahnhof aber der bahnhof wird nicht mehr
angefahren das gleis wurde stillgelegt
das wieder zu reaktivieren wir sind
verkauft aber nicht mehr reaktivieren
doch die strecke runter und dann cottbus
da sind ja genau die planung um da den
ausbau weiter voran zu bringen selbst
wenn die gleise jetzt zum teil über
wachsen sind also das müssen wir wieder
in die ländlichen räume bringen
gesundheitsversorgung haben einen
anderen landkreis oben bei uns im norden
ja dass wir eine versorgung schaffen die
dafür sorgt dass wir krankenhaus
kooperiert mit niedergelassenen ärzten
mit therapeuten um die versorgung auch
im ländlichen raum sicherzustellen das
bedeutet aber es braucht zusätzliche
mittel vom bund und genau das will ich
tun damit wir die situation die sie ja
zurecht beschrieben haben nicht in den
städten alle sagen hier explodieren die
mieten und die menschen vom land in die
städte ziehen oder angebote nicht dass
in brandenburg regieren die grünen mit
in der kenya koalition und ich glaube
der eindruck den er andreas schildert
ist auch der dass die grünen ja durchaus
etwas vorhaben und machen tun machen
aber das falsche tun also sie sprechen
davon dass biberdämme gebaut werden aber
dann gibt es eben kein bus und die die
leute fühlen sich dadurch nicht besser
dass ich dieses brisante straße gesehen
also da kämpfen wir mittlerweile 30
jahre um dass diese straße saniert wird
jetzt werden sich tausende von euro in
die hand genommen um diese straße von
dem biber zu sichern daher war das land
brandenburg aber was ist mit den
gemeindestraßen die unsere gemeinde ist
in der haushaltssicherung fast alle im
urlaub bruch sind in der
haushaltssicherung also wir können nur
noch das notwendigste oder die
pflichtaufgaben das geld in der hand
nehmen für was anderes haben wenn ich
das geld wenn unsere gemeindestraßen
jetzt unterhält wird da stellt sich an
landkreis und das land in das die arena
finanzieren ja wie soll ich eine straße
sanieren die vom biber und erhöht wurde
die mit 61 70.000 euro kosten soll und
da werden die kommunen diese kleinen nun
alleine gelassen und jetzt über jahre
schon so noch einmal antworten und dann
müssen wir weitermachen ich teile das
problem total und es gibt viele kommunen
die kommen selber aus eigener kraft
nicht raus auch manche größere städte
frankfurt oder in der nachbarschaft hat
das gleiche problem und deswegen braucht
es einen altschuldenfonds wo wir
kommunen entschulden von bundesseite mit
den ländern aus weil ansonsten sind sie
wie bei sich vor ort mit blick auf
straße aber auch bei vielen sozialen
aufgaben nicht mehr handlungsfähig und
das kann es geben und deswegen müssen
diese hoch verschuldeten kommunen die
dann im fall wenn es bei ihnen also ist
ihre aber entschieden ist da stehen wir
sind nicht hoch verschuldet aber wir
haben keine mittel um weitere ausgaben
zu tätigen also dass nicht alle die
einwanderungs kommune haben sie doch ja
aber eine haushaltssicherung heißt ja
nicht total verschuldet das heißt dass
wir wenig geld
und mit diesem haushalt nicht heißen
dass wir verschuldet sind wir können die
pflicht auch schön erfüllen aber wir
können nicht andere aufgaben erfüllen
und wie man sieht wichtige sachen in die
hand zu nehmen um die kitas weiter
auszubauen wir jetzt wohl auch über die
schule gesprochen da steht so eine
kleine gemeinde damit mit einer
grundschule wie sollen wir das
finanzieren das geht gar nicht weil er
ein fast den punkt altschulden vorangeht
den werden sie sicherlich auch in
koalitionsverhandlungen erst mal durch
bringen und deswegen ist es so wichtig
dass grüne sehr stark werden bei
freiwillige aufgaben das ist ja einst
auch ein bisschen absoluten dinge und
hat mir viel
grün kita und soziales freiwillige
aufgaben sind auch das ist aus meiner
sicht eine falsche haltung weil das
gehört zum leben dazu dass es
kernbestand vom leben und deswegen ja
werden wir ich bin also irgendwie jungs
von trainer andreas vielen dank fürs
kommen auch dieses gespräch muss
eigentlich noch fortgesetzt werden
frau weber wir haben noch jemanden in
der partner an bord sind so viele
brannten dass man erst mal aus leipzig
und wir machen jetzt ein experiment was
wir in dieser serie noch nicht hatten
wir schalten nach leipzig und versuchen
ursula buchheim hier dazu zu holen wo
sein buch haben wollte eigentlich gerne
hier im studio sein geht aber nicht
wegen quarantäne frau buchheim bitte ihr
anliegen ihre frage an annalena baerbock
ich grüße sie als leipzig hallo für mich
ist seit der inder ein wichtiges thema
die emanzipation und gleichberechtigung
der frauen in unserer gesellschaft
geworden nach der wende deshalb weil es
für mich als gleichberechtigte frauen in
der ddr dieses thema nicht gut aber
nun hatte ich das gefühl das ist mit der
gleichberechtigung rückwärts findet in
den letzten jahren hat sich hier einiges
gebessert das muss ich sagen aber aus
meiner sicht hatten wir noch viel
handlungsbedarf
frau berghoff ihre partei wird dieses
problem mit staatlich ort mit der quote
und mit ländern lösen
glauben sie dass das gelingen kann wenn
sie bei dieser herangehensweise
ungefähr 20 prozent der bevölkerung
ansprechen
und übrigen völlig in ihrer verfasstheit
unserer gesellschaft vorbei agieren frau
buch in vielen dank die bildqualität ist
etwa so als würden wir nach nowosibirsk
schalten es ist nur in leipzig knapp 400
kilometer entfernt es geht um es zu
ändern und es geht um die frage von
buchheim sie haben uns vorher
geschrieben sprach diktatur verhilft
nicht zur gleichberechtigung ja passt
aber zur daseinsvorsorge schnelles
internet internet an jeden ort und jena
nicht danke öffnen ihre frage und ich
hoffe sie sind nicht selbst betroffen
sondern in quarantäne weil sie kontakt
hatten auf jeden fall alles gute
mit blick auf die frage ja wir sind bei
der gleichberechtigung auch im jahr 2021
nicht da wo wir sein sollten und gerade
sie haben es angesprochen
manche themen wie zum beispiel gleicher
lohn für gleiche arbeit weiter
ehemaligen ddr für frauen eine
selbstverständlichkeit und wir haben
jetzt 30 jahre später eine
lohnunterschiede unbereinigt von 18
prozent und selbst beim gleichen job man
macht genau die gleiche tätigkeit
kriegen frauen im schnitt sechs prozent
weniger lohn deswegen auf die frage was
ist mein wichtigstes gleichstellungs
thema genau dass endlich dafür zu sorgen
dass männer und frauen gleich bezahlt
werden für die gleiche tätigkeit und
daher kommt ja der große unterschied bei
unterschiedlichen jobs gerade in
sozialen berufen in der pflege in der
kita wo viele frauen arbeiten endlich
für höhere löhne zu sorgen
ich glaube ich habe operation verstanden
sie hat gesagt das ist wichtig dass es
gut aber durch das gender erreicht man
diese gleichberechtigung auch nicht da
stimmt und er ist ein wunderlicher genau
und deswegen wunder ich mich auch dass
wir heute nicht deswegen danke für ihre
frage in vielen vielen anderen sendungen
dann immer beim thema frauen über gender
star reden weil das für mich jetzt nicht
das große politische thema ist sondern
eher eine frage der höflichkeit dass
sich jemand der männlich ist in der
männlichen sprachform anspreche und eine
frau als moderatorin anspreche das ist
jetzt nicht die hauptaufgabe von politik
sondern eigentlich für mich was von
anstand und höflichkeit menschen so
anzusprechen wie sie sich selbst als
geschlecht sehen oder auch definieren
dankeschön vorgefahren sind ansätze aus
plastik dabei waren
30 danke nach leipzig so wir sind bei
den themenkomplexen
gesellschaft gesellschaftspolitik und
wir wollen uns auch noch mit dem komplex
migration integration beschäftigen wir
haben an allen bei und sie hat selbst
migrationshintergrund
und hat eine konkrete frage bitte schön
schönen guten abend frau berg mein name
ist anna bühren ich bin mitglied bei der
afg und bin auch kommunalpolitisch aktiv
und ich denke es herrscht breiter
konsens übrigens auch in meiner partei
dass die menschen die in afghanistan
unserer bundeswehr geholfen haben und
die sich für westliche werte eingesetzt
haben und so hilfe verdienen und alleine
vor dem hintergrund meiner
familienbiografie kann ich nicht
kategorisch gegen einwanderung sein
meine eltern ist und damals
aufgrund ihres christlichen glaubens aus
dem kommunistischen vietnam geflohen und
sind überaus dankbar für die chancen die
sie hier erhalten haben und meine frage
handelt sich jetzt natürlich nicht um
einwanderung allgemein sondern gibt mein
frage jeder in eine andere richtung und
zwar haben wir bei den evakuierungsflüge
aus kabul gesehen dass wir eben nicht
immer wissen wen wir zu uns holen dass
auch der eindruck entstanden ist dass
überwiegend junge männer in den
flugzeugen saßen und auch das wie medien
berichteten sogar bereits abgeschobene
und verurteilte straftäter wieder ins
land geholt wurden
sie sagen sich wenn wir es richtig
verstehen vor einer ungeordneten
zuwanderung die jetzt durch die
entwicklung in afghanistan einsatz kommt
vielleicht zu meiner frage und zwar
genau ich möchte betonen dass ich weiß
dass nicht alle asylbewerber strafe
werden die wenigsten werden das aber es
geht mir um die problemfälle und zwar
zeigt die polizeiliche
kriminalitätsstatistik ganz deutlich
dass vor allem einwanderer aus
muslimischen ländern
überrepräsentiert sind insbesondere bei
gewalt gegen frauen
und ich habe zwei fragen an sie die
erste frage und meine wichtigste frage
lautet da ihre partei kommt ein
kategorisch gegen abschiebung nach
afghanistan ist möchte ich von ihnen
wissen wie sie falls die kanzlerin
werden die frauen hierzulande schützen
möchten dann meine zweite frage halten
sie es aus den genannten gründen nicht
für sinnvoll wenn die neue
bundesregierung in zukunft die
einwanderung aus muslimischen ländern
eingrenzen will
also zur ersten frage ganz klar die
abschiebung nach afghanistan die müssen
gestoppt und ausgesetzt werden weil es
gibt im völkerrecht
wir haben jetzt schon stopp aber das
muss jetzt dauerhaft sichergestellt
werden weil menschen die hier leben
können ja nicht in der unsicherheit
seien eine afghanische familie die ich
seit langem kennen damit kindern in der
schule die nach wie vor sorge haben
müssen wenn sie nicht sagen können wir
bleiben dauerhaft hier dass sie
vielleicht fürchten dass sie irgendwann
in ein land wissen wo die taliban jetzt
an der regierung sind deswegen ja bin
ich dafür einen konsequenten
abschiebestopp das jetzt straftäter
angesprochen haben auch das ist ja schön
dass im rechtsstaat leben und da wird
kein unterschied gemacht mit blick auf
nationalitäten wie ein straftäter ist
gehört ins gefängnis und wenn menschen
nicht abgeschoben werden da nicht soviel
gefängnis sein und wenn sie gefährdet
sind dann müssen sie rund um die uhr
sicherheitsüberprüft seien aber die
stärke unseres landes ist dass wir ja
nicht recht nach einzelfall auswählen
sondern uns an völkerrecht halten und
völkerrecht sagt klar man kann nicht in
ein land abschieben wo menschen die
todesstrafe droht oder wo wir jetzt mit
blick auf die taliban sehen dass eine
herrschaft jetzt an der tagesordnung ist
wo tagtäglich menschen ermordet werden
weil sie sich für ihre freiheit und für
demokratische rechte zum beispiel als
frauenrechtlerin einsetzen wie gesagt
auch die position meiner partei ist es
das eben auch frauen recht lang geholfen
wird
dass
ich glaub ich weiß es ein bisschen
besser so
im bundesheer lich gesagt für euch davor
den vertretern ihrer partei ganz ganz
andere worte da werden nämlich nicht die
menschenrechte für alle menschen geteilt
sondern es wird unterschieden zwischen
deutschen und dann sie ihre frage war ja
auch ob ich kategorisch ab gegen bin
dass menschen aus muslimischen ländern
nach deutschland kommen wir haben
menschenrechte sind unteilbar die gelten
für alle in der welt und deswegen ist
natürlich absolut nicht zu akzeptieren
zu sagen weil menschen aus gewissen
ländern kommen sprechen wir ihren ihre
menschenrechte ab und ja ihr recht auf
asyl ab sondern es ist immer eine
einzelfallentscheidung wo man prüft hat
jemand ein recht auf asyl egal woher er
kommt und wenn er kein recht hat weil
sie haben gesagt wir sind kategorisch
gegen abschiebungen wenn er kein recht
auf asyl hat dann muss es auch
rückführung in die entsprechenden länder
geben aber menschenrechte gelten
universell für alle menschen gleich noch
einmal gegeben
halten sie es nicht für sinnvoller die
menschen heimatnah unterzubringen und
wissen sie ich stelle diese frage weil
ich angst vor einem neuen 2015 habe und
ich glaube nicht dass ich die einzige
frau bin die angst vor einer weiteren
masseneinwanderung hat und
denkt ich denke da an mir aus kandel an
die drei frauen die in würzburg ermordet
wurden und an leoni aus wien und ich
hatte gehofft dass sie eine bessere eine
bessere antwort auf meine frage finden
würden aber die angst die ich und viele
andere frauen auch haben konnten sie mir
heute auch nicht nehmen ja ich habe
komplett andere meinung das ist
offensichtlich
weil es für mich gilt dass jeder mensch
die gleichen rechte hat und wenn es ein
vergewaltiger ein straftäter gibt da
muss er verurteilt und ins gefängnis
gebracht werden und wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass jede frau in deutschland
sicher ist aber dass ich jetzt haben ein
paar zahlen gekommen sind die größte
gefahr leider in unserem land ist dass
eine frau von ihrem eigenen partner oder
ehemann getötet wird jeden
jeden tag versucht dass ein partner
seine frau umzubringen jeden dritten tag
gelingt das und darf mir egal welcher
herkunft sondern das müssen wir
verhindern frauen egal welcher herkunft
vor tätern egal welcher herkunft besser
zu schützen von mir
wir bedanken uns bei ihnen dass sie
hergekommen sind vorbei und wir wollen
noch zum nächsten thema kommen
wenn sie im kanzleramt grüne ziele
umsetzen würden dann würde die deutsche
wirtschaft jedenfalls zum teil durchaus
mit skepsis darauf schauen was kommt da
auf uns zu fragt sich eine unternehmerin
die sie jetzt im film kennen lernen
werden und die dann auch gleich bei uns
im studio ist
[Musik]
heike horn ist geschäftsführerin des
kaliherstellers schaefer kalk indiz das
familienunternehmen in fünfter
generation beschäftigt weltweit 700
mitarbeiter von der sprengung bis zur
verarbeitung die kalk herstellung ist
ein energieintensiver prozess bei dem
viel co2 freigesetzt wird
findet der kernprozess unseres
unternehmens statt wir brennen den
kalkstein weil über 1000 grad insgesamt
entsteht dabei etwa eine tonne co2 pro
tonne geplanten halt die steigenden co2
preise eine enorme belastung sie
arbeiten an der entwicklung
umweltfreundlicher technologien doch
dafür brauchen sie zeit die
herausforderung klimaneutral zu
produzieren nimmt das unternehmen an
fordert aber wir brauchen auf der einen
seite investitions unterstützung wir
brauchen aber auch viele denen wir
arbeiten können wenn die ziele wechseln
nicht verschieben oder in dem fall unser
woche verschärft werden
kalt ist ein wichtiger rohstoff für
viele industriebereiche zu hoch
gesteckten klimaziele könnten so die
gesamte deutsche industrie in schieflage
bringen und damit ihre sechs millionen
beschäftigten
unsere größte sorge werde es tatsächlich
das feld die klimaziele durch die
industrialisierung erreichen dass wir
als unternehmen nicht mehr bestehen
könnten dafür braucht die industrie
insgesamt in deutschland nicht mehr
bestehen könnte
standortnachteile durch zu hohe deutsche
klimaschutzauflagen ob das im sinne der
deutschen wirtschaft ist bezweifelt
sie ist jetzt auf
die hat fragen ja guttenberg zunächst
mal wir haben einen kleinen eindruck
bekommen was unser unternehmen ausmacht
das thema dekarbonisierung ist für uns
als co2 und energieintensive industrien
riesenherausforderung
schon auch mal zwei drittel des co2 was
wir freisetzen aus dem kalkstein kommt
also aus der produktion selber aus dem
prozess von an sich wir arbeiten heute
bereits mit anderen unternehmen auch mit
forschungseinrichtungen daran die klima
herstellung die kalk herstellung
klimaneutral zu gestalten
schon auch weil kalt ein sehr
wesentlicher ansatz schafft für eine
vielzahl von industrie für industrien
und auch für wertschöpfungsketten ist
die problematik ist dass die technologie
hierzu heute teilweise noch in den
kinderschuhen steckt die muss weiter
entwickelt werden die muss jetzt einfach
umgesetzt werden das braucht zeit das
braucht auch enorme finanzielle mittel
zur forschung letzten endes auch zur
investition das braucht auch
rahmenbedingungen sie haben es vorhin
kurz genannt wie die verfügbarkeit von
wasserstoff aber auch von enormen mengen
an grünem strom welche schwierigkeiten
das bereitet diesen bereitzustellen
haben wir auch schon kurz angesprochen
meine frage geht daher wie wollen sie
die rahmenbedingungen und auch die
planungssicherheit
bereitstellen die wir benötigen um diese
wichtige transformation voranzutreiben
damit wir nicht vorher durch ein immer
höheres tempo und auch durch aktuell
immer steigende belastungen die damit
einhergehen wettbewerbsverzerrungen
vorher zugrunde gehen
vielen dank ich meine beitrag hat ja
auch noch mal deutlich gemacht wie viel
passiert ist in den letzten jahren
gerade in der industrie gerade in der
grundstoffindustrie wo ganz ganz viele
unternehmen sowie ihr gesagt haben auch
im stahlbereich im zement bereich wir
werden jetzt klimaneutral und wie soll
das funktionieren
mit klaren rahmenbedingungen und ich
teile was sie sagen wo nicht alle jahre
die ziele wechseln sondern wenn ihr bis
2040 mitte der 2040 er klimaneutral
werden wollen dann habe ich konkret
vorgeschlagen auch mit teilen des bds
diskutiert ein industrie packt wo die
unternehmen die branchen die jetzt sagen
wir stellen um wir brauchen wie sie ja
im beitrag auch schon gesagt haben dafür
riesige investitionssummen um die
technologie umzustellen dass es
unterstützt wird mit einem klimavertrag
von der bundesregierung und dann in den
jahrzehnten wenn sie dann mit ihren
produkten wettbewerbsfähig sind dass es
zum eine standortsicherung garantie gibt
damit die arbeitsplätze wirklich auch in
deutschland bleiben und die
entsprechenden gelder dann zurückgezahlt
werden und das gute ist auch da wieder
auf der europäischen ebene wird das ja
genau jetzt diskutiert und es braucht
jetzt eine bundesregierung die sich für
solche industriepartnerschaften jetzt
konsequent einsetzt mit blick auf die
abwanderung in andere länder zum
beispiel durch kambodschas mit access
also durch ausgleichsmaßnahmen an der
grenze dafür sorgt wenn in china ganz
ganz billig produziert wird das nicht
der europäische markt geflutet wird
sondern dass die dann ausgleichszahlung
leisten müssen damit sie ihr unternehmen
ihren betrieb und damit auch die
arbeitsplätze in deutschland
wettbewerbsfähig erhalten können weil
die sorge von frau horn ist glaube ich
dass die grünen ihnen nicht genug zeit
gewähren richtig für die umstellung ich
habe mir das ist sicherlich ein ganz
wesentlicher punkt vor allem der punkt
ist auch dass wir in deutschland auf die
europäische gesetzgebung der wir im
emissionshandel gesetz auch unterliegen
immer noch einen drauf wartet das immer
noch eine belastung oben drauf kommt
dass jetzt ein
bundesemissionsschutzgesetz oben drauf
kommt dass im eeg dinge anders geregelt
werden und dass wir hier bereits
innerhalb von europa große unterschiede
sehen wie diese themen gehandhabt werden
wie diese themen behandelt werden und
dass hier das tempo in deutschland immer
noch ein stückchen angezogen würden ich
sage man das bild ist wie ein lastesel
dem packe ich immer noch einen oben
drauf und sagte jetzt muss auch noch
doppelt so schnell rennen und dann habe
ich ein bisschen die sorge dass wir das
ziel nicht erreichen werden und dass wir
das ziel den letzten endes doch
erreichen indem der eine oder andere
unternehmer an der stelle aufgeben muss
weil er letzten endes da nicht mehr ins
raster rein passt und dass wir ich
glaube ich für uns alle nicht gut genau
und deswegen will ich dass wir den
wohlstand und die industrie ist das
rückgrat für unseren wohlstand dass wir
das nicht nur in deutschland erhalten
sondern so schnell klimaneutral machen
weil in der situation hier unternehmen
ja wahrscheinlich auch steht im
internationalen wettbewerb sind jetzt
die chinesen schneller oder sind in
automobilwirtschaft im zweifel die
amerikaner schneller und dafür braucht
es sicherheit das wird in europa
garantieren schnell genug zu sein und
bei den unternehmen wo ich in der
letzten zeit jetzt immer wieder war die
sagen mit blick auf die sorge geht es zu
schnell vor allem wir brauchen jetzt mal
diese fördermittelbescheide
einzementiert steller der umbauen will
der sagt ich kann nicht anderthalb jahre
auf den fördermittelbescheid erwarten
sondern ich brauche den jetzt und das
ist genau mein angebot zu sagen sie
können schon mal loslegen und sie müssen
nicht warten bis der
fördermittelbescheid da ist sondern sie
können ihre technologie jetzt einsetzen
weil es ist ein wettlauf der zeit und
ich bin aber überzeugt sowohl früher
made in germany die besten produkte
waren das auch die klimaneutrale
produkte der zukunft hier in deutschland
gebaut werden wenn wirtschaft und
politik an der stelle zusammen aber ist
das für sie eine perspektive was jetzt
gehört im grundsatz her schon stimme ich
ihnen auch vom grundsatz her zu wir
müssen alles daran tun diese
technologien zu entwickeln
nur wenn wir hier von millionen von
anderthalb jahren oder auch von zehn
jahren reden da werden diese
technologien noch nicht so auch also die
müssen entwickler werden müssen
umgesetzt werden das braucht zeit das
braucht noch einige fünf bis zehn jahre
zeit und sie benötigen für eine
infrastruktur die hatte er zur verfügung
steht was hilft das wenn wir
technologien entwickelt haben wenn wir
die wasserstoff infrastruktur nicht
haben wenn wir die erneuerbaren
energien also den grünen strom nicht
ausreichend ausgebaut haben um diese
technologien dann wirklich auch
klimaneutral zu nutzen und da habe ich
die große sorge dass wir das mit den
ambitionierten zielen auch tatsächlich
hinbekommen
kraftaufbau den wir hier hatten und
genau das müssen wir jetzt
zusammenbringen die grünen strom
brauchen müssen wir windkraft aufbauen
und vor allem die wasserstoff
infrastruktur dass wenn der wasserstoff
in den niederlanden oder auch an unseren
häfen ankommt dass wir dann der
infrastruktur haben die auch zu ihnen
ins kalkwerk wird und wir können nicht
alles über einen kamm scheren im bereich
stahl ist man weiter das heißt die
können jetzt schon mal loslegen die
brauchen die wasserstoff in den nächsten
fünf jahren spätestens und im bereich
cult wenn sagen da braucht es noch ein
bisschen länger müssen wir den branchen-
dann auch die zeit geben wirklich
umzustellen damit wir jetzt loslegen und
nicht wie die letzten jahre noch weitere
kostbare zeit vertrauen das haben wir
verstanden dankeschön frau bärbel
dankeschön frau anja die situation der
unternehmen ist das eine wir wollen ja
zum schluss noch mal über eine ganz
andere zukunftsfrage sprechen nämlich
über die rente und da haben wir zwei
sehr unterschiedliche herren
zufälligerweise jetzt hier sitzen dass
es zwei männer sind der eine kümmert
sich um die rente jetzt und der andere
und die rente künftig bitte mal erst
ihre fragen stellt euch sagen haben mein
name ist bald leopold kommen wir vom
frankleben das licht prallt später statt
am geiseltalsee
bin 66 jahre aber 45 jahre und da wollen
natürlich arbeitet bin auch übungsleiter
wie manche ich fordere gehen dort die
häufig von zu hause aus in den
regenzeiten das ist nämlich auch nicht
so einfach da würde ich mehr kosten wenn
da was passieren wird und darin auch den
45 jahren und dahin wollen arbeit 728
euro rente ich habe er pro reli
gestorben musste ich nur eine leichte
arbeit suchen ich bin schlosser
schweißer schmidt alles gemacht und
jetzt habe ich noch 45 jahren 228 euro
rente da freilich sieht mal wie kann ich
da
können sie nicht und deswegen ist mein
vorschlag auch dass wir die garantie
rente die ja zum teil angegangen wurde
aber so erhöhen dass man mindestens 1200
euro bekommt und nicht was sie dann
vielleicht tun müssen jetzt derzeit
aufstocken obwohl sie ihr ganzes leben
lang gearbeitet haben das für mich nur
frage auch von von respekt und das heißt
die garantierente so aufzustocken dass
man dann auch davon leben kann und seine
familie mit ich habe auch zwei enkel ich
habe auch
eine wohnung und alles drum und dran und
muss immer wieder die anderen auto form
und wenn die benzinpreise wirklich so
kommen das wissen wir ja nicht im museum
soll nicht aber das ist für mich auch
ein punkt mit blick auf den zehn preise
diskutieren wir ja in allen bereichen
aber
die benzinpreise erhöhung selbst wenn es
sie nicht gäbe haben sie eine viel zu
geringe rente das heißt wir können nicht
über den klimaschutz alle sozialen
probleme in unserem land leben sondern
wir brauchen vor allen dingen eine
andere sozialpolitik und dafür sorgt
dass menschen den geringes einkommen
eine geringe rente haben auch endlich
dazu befähigt werden durch eine
rentenerhöhung in der garantie rente
oder einen gesetzlichen mindestlohn von
12 euro da kann man davon auch
vernünftig leben nehmen wir vielleicht
mal den jugend wander vorne dazu sie
machen sich ganz andere sorgen und da
geht es um die zukunft vielleicht
stellen sie sich auch kurz vor und ihre
frage an vorher schön grün habe mein
armes und äppler ich bin 26 stelle jetzt
am ende meines studiums und kurz vor dem
berufseinstieg und
wie man eben gehört hat die rente ist
sehr vage darauf kann man sich nicht
verlassen und gerade wegen und trotzdem
einer relativ guten ausbildung mache ich
mir auch sorgen um die rente und frage
mich wie das ganze bewerkstelligt werden
soll beziehungsweise selbst möchte ich
in die gesetzliche rente gar nicht sein
zahlen überhaupt sondern das ganze
lieber privat lösen und da ist meine
frage an sie im ersten moment wie wollen
sie oder was wollten sie dafür tun um
mein vertrauen in die rente überhaupt
wieder zu gewinnen und auf der anderen
seite wie möchten sie dass in den
nächsten vier jahren bewerkstelligen ist
das überhaupt realistisch dass das
passiert und können sie das in solchen
zeitraum überhaupt umsetzen
also zum einen ist die gesetzliche rente
für mich einer der treiber unseres
sozialsystems und deswegen will ich dass
wir die gesetzliche rente deutlich
deutlich stärken und junge menschen wie
sie in die gesetzliche rentenkasse
eintreten und dann wenn man sie so alt
sind wie ihr sitznachbar davon auch
vernünftig leben können dafür müssen wir
jetzt die weichenstellung treffen und
das sind vier punkte zum einen das war
mit blick auch auf den mindestlohn wenn
wir löhne haben wo man zum einen jetzt
schon seine familie nicht ernähren kann
und wo klar ist man endet am ende in
altersarmut dann stimmt irgendwas im
systemisch deswegen die anhebung des
gesetzlichen mindestlohns auf 12 euro
das reicht für die rente noch nicht
komplett sondern der arbeitgeber muss
ein anteil zahlen der eigentlich auf 15
euro stundenlohn berechnet ist zweiter
ich hatte mir vor ein bisschen mit blick
auf frauen frauen arbeiten ganz vielen
teilzeit in deutschland und seien damit
auch nicht komplett in die rente mit ein
obwohl sie vollzeit arbeiten wollen das
heißt frauenerwerbstätigkeit durch gute
kita plätze betreuungsplätze zu erhöhen
dritter punkt wir brauchen fachkräfte
zuwanderung auch deswegen brauchen wir
zuwanderung in den deutschen
arbeitsmarkt
mit blick auf pflegeberufe aber auch mit
blick auf die rente und der vierte punkt
ist daher wie sie wiederkam gesetzliche
rentenversicherung
ich möchte das auch vor allem
selbstständige oder abgeordnete wie ich
in die gesetzliche rentenversicherung
einzahlen um diese dann
generationengerechten und für sie eine
faire rente im alter zu ermöglichen wo
wir wirklich dass vielleicht mal so
zusammenfassen
weitere träger aber es ist auch klar das
wird teuer also sie versprechen hier an
der aufstockung fast ums doppelte 500
euro 728 zu 1200 der junge mann will
auch seine gewissheit für die zukunft
sie werden das doch nur schaffen wenn
die staatlichen leistungen für die rente
insgesamt steigen die liegen jetzt schon
bei ungefähr einem drittel 30 prozent
des bundeshaushaltes also muss sich der
steuerzahler darauf einstellen dass sein
beitrag für die rente für die sicherheit
von herrn lepper noch größer wird nie
sondern mit blick auf die beitragssätze
haben wir jetzt ja schon leichten
anstieg der beschlossen wurden ist aber
den gilt es zu stabilisieren weil sonst
ist es total ungerecht für generationen
die heute jung sind wenn die
beitragssätze explodieren und auf der
anderen seite gibt es von mir die
sicherheit dass wir mit blick auf das
rentenniveau sagen das wird nicht weiter
abgesenkt sondern das müssen wir bei
mindestens 48 prozent halten auch wieder
damit man von der rente auch leben kann
und deswegen braucht jetzt schnell die
maßnahmen die ich angesprochen habe und
wir haben jetzt schon den punkt dass der
steuerzuschüsse geben und das braucht es
auch weiterhin aber auch hier gilt ich
meine sich erfasst der leitfaden dieser
sendung dass die frage ist wenn wir die
großen probleme die jetzt acht jahre
lang nicht angegangen worden sind wenn
wir sie jetzt nicht angehen dann wird es
für die jetzige generation nicht besser
werden und für die zukünftigen auch
nicht und deswegen bin ich so überzeugt
dass wir an solchen fragen wirklich
stellschrauben ändern müssen so wirkung
wir müssen auf die uhr schauen denn das
heute journal er wartet schon leider
können nicht mehr alle dran kommen heute
abend
frau berg sie haben uns eingangs
verraten sie setzen auf sieg sie wollen
nach wie vor für den sieg kämpfen wenn
das aber nicht gelingt das müssen am
ende ja doch noch mal fragen wenn das
nicht gelingt was dann werden sie dann
vize kanzlerin und außenministerin oder
finanzministerin hat allerdings ihr
kollege habe schon die den finger
gehoben das werden wir seit dem 26
heute sehen und da wir ja schöner weise
in einer demokratie leben finde ich auch
alle demokraten wissen miteinander
sprechen wenn das wahlergebnis vorliegt
wer da mit wem koalieren kann aber ich
bin auch aus dem sport ja wir sind jetzt
kurz vor ende der zweiten halbzeit und
da zerbreche ich mir nicht den kopf
darüber was ist wenn es am ende nichts
geworden ist sondern gebe jetzt alles
dafür dass wir wirklich die erneuerung
in unserem land mit starken grünen an
der spitze schaffen dass sie haben ja
frau bernburg in den letzten wochen ihre
beiden konkurrenten ziemlich dicht
erlebt und kennengelernt olaf scholz und
armin laschet zum beispiel im trial
immer wieder erlebt wenn wir ja mal die
politischen unterschiede zwischen ihnen
und den beiden beiseite lassen sondern
ganz persönlich fragen wem vertrauen sie
mehr von den beiden
fangfrage fangfrage ja da das
heute-journal gleich anfängt haben wir
vielleicht
alle wenn wir einen wirklichen aufbruch
wollen vertraue ich darauf dass es nur
mit einer grün geführten bundesregierung
klappt weil sowohl die cdu als auch die
spd fordert scholz und laschet die haben
jetzt acht jahre lang gesagt wir müssen
uns erneuern sie haben es nicht getan
deswegen klarer aufbruch mit grün mit
mir als kanzlerkandidatin das war
klartext mit annalena baerbock für sie
noch der hinweis genauso wie diese
sendung können sie natürlich auch die
ausgaben mit armin laschet und olaf
scholz in der zdf mediathek finden und
für den ein oder anderen für die ein
oder andere nachfrage den einen oder
anderen faktencheck das ist versprochen
so haben wir es auch in den letzten
sendungen gemacht stehen kollegen heute
nacht schon bereit und werden das
checken was anna lena berger abgesagt
hat soll er alle seine richtigkeit haben
kann man morgen nachlesen also der zdf
heute wir danken ihnen zu hause
natürlich für das interesse unseren
gästen hier für die vielen tollen fragen
danke und ihn frau bewarb für die
antworten fielen dank danke auflief und
jetzt geht es direkt weiter mit
weihnachtsmützen versprechen und ich
glaube das ist verzeihlich zu maria
slaughter im heute journal
schönen abend noch aus berlin vielen
dank an sie alles
[Applaus]